des mots d'une nouvelle télé de lg là
elle passe en mode un curieux c'est à
dire que la télé est en train de cinq
heures des tout seul l'écran se plie
c'est de l'oled donc ça permet
effectivement d'avancé de flexibilité au
niveau de l'écran comme on l'a sur des
écrans qui se plie de smartphones et
puis alors on va voir différents
affichages voire du multi view on peut
aller franchement loin en termes de
gaming c'est vrai j'aurais donc pu la
voir en moniteur il va être plat vous
pouvez la voir en écran pour venir jouer
et bien il va être un tueur v c'est vous
qui choisissez et là regardez vont venir
modifier le mode dont clara plat il va
pas sans votre cela tu es là il en train
de bouger pour devenir complètement plat
je trouve ça absolument complètement
dingue c'est le lg oled flex